Hi everybody, I'm Jonathan Schrantz and today I
got another Tactical Challenge for you
So when you see the image on your screen
go ahead pause your video and see if you
can solve it
So in this position it is White to move
I will go ahead and give you guys a hint today
If you haven't already figured it out
I'm trying to take advantage of the
fact that the Queen doesn't have a whole
lot of squares that she can go to
She is a little bit close in our territory
so see if you can somehow take
advantage of that fact
Here comes the answer: the best move in this position is
Re5! -- interfering with the Queen's
path and making a threat
I won't tell you what it is right away
but let's just look at what happens if we
play the most direct move we just take
your rook. Hopefully you can see what White
should play in this position: the move that
traps the Queen is g3 and the Queen
doesn't have anywhere to go so the best
you can do is at least get another
piece for it and here White has won some material
Going back if you see that
you're about to get trapped you may
think you're clever and perhaps you want
to try and move like h5 not tempted by
the exchange and i just created square
so my Queen can retreat back to h6 well
now still g3 is a strong move because after
you go back to h6 we can grab the pawn
on a5 -- now the Knight is hanging and
when you retreat the Knight among other
moves we can take on f5 and then take on
b7 and we have two pawns for the
exchange and a completely dominant
position
another very crafty move that you might
try going back to this position after
Re5 is the move Bd3
This also might be a confusing way to try to
confuse your opponent but it should also
be insufficient after a move like g3
let's try this crafty move: Bc2!
Well White here again get the
great position after first taking on c2
then trading the Queens
and here again White has won some
material and has a better position
Thank you everybody for watching
congrats to everybody was able to get
this one right
As always hit like, share, subscribe and
we'll see you next week for another
Tactical Challenge!